en deux mois j'ai arrêté
quitter la maison est complètement terminé
la force de faire quelque chose
Même pas tant de force et combien d'envies
fais quelque chose comme si tu
arrête de voir le sens de tout ça
J'ai eu de la chance avec le médecin qu'il a commencé
commencer à poser des questions
à peu près ce qui se passe
l'année dernière, mais aussi mon expérience dans
en général, il s'est avéré que
J'ai un trouble depuis longtemps mais sur
pendant ces mois c'est très fort
aggravé Et malheureusement juste en
côté de la dépression, alors maintenant je
je suis sous traitement
[musique]
ceci sans
Les epressants ne peuvent pas être achetés en pharmacie simplement
alors eux
délivré uniquement sur ordonnance, alors
ce qui a augmenté le nombre
la vente d'antidépresseurs est juste
reflète le fait que le nombre de patients qui
accepte vraiment ces écritures
vraiment augmenté je pense que c'est
expliqué en grande partie
s'inquiète que
n'a pas surgi en relation avec le dernier
événements
significativement diminué
ces gens qui sont pour ceux qui
doutent qu'ils éprouvent vraiment
peur qui en général ressemble beaucoup à un ami
sur un ami car dans ce cas c'est
il s'agit de quoi
il nous est difficile de planifier
l'avenir c'est la peur c'est toujours
perturbation de la planification future
[musique]